ya hemos estudiado en varios vídeos
gráficas como la que ves aquí
esta es la gráfica para una empresa en
particular tal vez sea una industria de
donas y podemos ver cómo se relaciona el
costo marginal con el costo variable
promedio y el costo total promedio
hace algunos vídeos estudiamos esta
profundidad podemos ver que inicialmente
la tendencia del costo marginal puede
descender ya que mientras la cantidad
producida aumenta cada unidad adicional
se puede beneficiar de cosas como la
especialización y después podemos ver el
costo marginal es decir el costo de cada
unidad adicional en función de la
cantidad producida y este empezará a
subir debido a cosas como los costos de
coordinación y luego hemos visto cómo es
que se relaciona con el costo variable
promedio cuando el costo marginal está
por debajo del costo variable promedio
cada unidad adicional va a disminuir el
costo variable promedio pero cuando la
curva de costo marginal cruza la curva
de costo variable promedio cada unidad
adicional
a aumentar el costo variable promedio lo
mismo pasa cuando cruza el costo total
promedio y por supuesto la diferencia
para cualquier cantidad producida entre
el costo variable promedio y el costo
total promedio es el costo fijo promedio
ahora con esto en mente vamos a pensar
en cómo esta empresa podría reaccionar
bajo diferentes condiciones en el
mercado vamos a suponer que está en un
mercado de competencia perfecta es
precio aceptante primero imagina en cuál
sería un posible escenario para esta
empresa imagina el precio aquí
llamémosle p subíndice 1 y en un vídeo
anterior dijimos que sería racional para
una empresa que maximiza sus ganancias
producir una cantidad donde se de la
intersección entre el costo marginal y
el ingreso marginal y si hablamos de un
mercado en competencia perfecta entonces
este precio no estará en función de la
cantidad de la empresa
es por ello que es horizontal y esto es
lo mismo que el ingreso marginal
entonces en esta situación en pesos 2001
la empresa producirá una cantidad que
subíndice 1 y esta es una buena
situación para la empresa porque el
precio que obtiene es mayor que su costo
total promedio lo que le dará una buena
cantidad de ganancias a la empresa
la ganancia será el precio menos el
costo total promedio que implica esa
cantidad por la cantidad producida
actual entonces dado que peso vílchez 1
es mayor que el costo total promedio
tenemos la situación donde la empresa es
rentable
ellos querrán quedarse en este mercado
pero debido a que tienes una empresa
rentable en este mercado existirán
muchas otras empresas rentables en ese
mismo mercado y probablemente ese
mercado atraiga nuevos participantes
otras personas van a decir oye yo quiero
hacer tanto dinero como esa empresa de
donas que tenemos aquí probablemente
tengas más empresas que entren al
mercado lo que probablemente reducirá
los precios
ahora se reducirá el precio hasta que se
vea más o menos así aquí tenemos el
ingreso marginal 2 y llamaré a este
subíndice 2 y bueno una empresa que
maximiza sus ganancias en este mundo
seguirá produciendo hasta que el costo
marginal sea igual al ingreso marginal
que en este caso es el precio entonces
tenemos esta cantidad en esta situación
subíndice 2 ahora en esta situación p
subíndice 2 es igual al costo total
promedio por lo que la empresa está en
un punto de equilibrio no tiene pérdidas
en ni ganancias ya que está en un punto
de equilibrio aquí la empresa es neutral
sobre si a largo plazo se mantiene en el
mercado o si se va del mercado pero ya
no es probable que traigan nuevos
participantes en el mercado tiene
sentido que la empresa se mantenga
operando en esta situación incluso a
largo plazo
al menos está en un punto de equilibrio
ahora imagina otro escenario imaginemos
este nivel de precio p subíndice 3 y por
alguna razón el precio del mercado
disminuyó hasta esto y ahora es racional
que la empresa esté produciendo esta
cantidad un subíndice 3 y en pesos
índice 3 pasan algunas cosas
interesantes ya que peso índice 3 es
menor que tu costo total promedio tu
empresa está obteniendo pérdidas déjame
escribirlo la empresa no es rentable
ahora bien seguramente te preguntarás
qué es lo que debe hacer la empresa
debería cerrar bueno a corto plazo no
tendría sentido para esta empresa cerrar
porque el precio que obtiene sigue
estando arriba del costo variable
promedio a corto plazo el costo fijo ya
se ha gastado así que podrías obtener
todavía alguna ganancia adicional
sigues produciendo por lo tanto siempre
que el precio sea mayor que el costo
variable promedio bueno sin considerar
el costo fijo ellos siguen haciendo algo
de dinero y eso les ayuda a compensar
sus costos fijos dos cosas van a pasar
ellos pueden seguir operando a corto
plazo pueden seguir operando a corto
plazo pero qué debe hacer esta empresa a
largo plazo bueno a largo plazo no tiene
sentido estar en un mercado donde no
obtienes ganancia y a largo plazo ellos
deberían cerrar en general la
terminología cuando las personas dicen
oye empiezas a producir o te detienes a
corto plazo o usualmente dicen oye tú
deberías cerrar u operar a corto plazo
ya largo plazo decimos oye me vas a
vender tu empresa o de alguna forma vas
a desmantelarla o vas a desarrollar
nuevas fábricas
y eso tiene que ver con salir o entrar a
la industria y claro puedes tener un
escenario peor para la empresa que es
justo aquí donde tienes a peu subíndice
4 en teoría es donde inter secamos la
curva del costo marginal y entonces aquí
tienes aqu subíndice 4 aquí no tiene
lógica que la compañía opere en ningún
sentido ya que peso vílchez 4 es menor
que tu costo total promedio querrás
salir a largo plazo salir del mercado
pero no debes esperar a largo plazo
no debes esperar para vender tus
fábricas ya que peso 24 es menor que tu
costo variable promedio y por lo tanto
también deberías de cerrar a corto plazo
en resumen desde el punto de vista de
una empresa quieres estar en peso índice
1 donde obtienes ganancia pero vas a
atraer nuevos participantes
en su 2002 eres una empresa neutral
entre salir o entrar al mercado a largo
plazo o que otras personas entre en el
mercado ya que estás en un punto de
equilibrio en p subíndice 3 a largo
plazo querrás salir del mercado ya que
no eres rentable tu precio en la
cantidad razonable producir está por
debajo del costo total promedio por lo
tanto es recomendable a largo plazo
salir del mercado pero como peso índice
3 es mayor que tu costo variable
promedio en esta cantidad racional
deberías mantenerte operando a corto
plazo para finalizar el último escenario
es peso 2004 donde el precio es tan bajo
que no tiene sentido incluso operar a
corto plazo